an historic day in our nation's capital
tens of thousands of people showing
their solidarity for the Jewish State at
today's March for Israel in Washington
D.C it's a breath of fresh air after a
month of vicious anti-semitic threats
and pramas lunacy in the wake of the
October 7 Terror attacks lawmakers
celebrities and ordinary Americans
banding together calling for the release
of Israeli hostage is and denouncing the
growing wave of
anti-Semitism we stand with Israel we
stand with Israel the calls for a
ceasefire are outrageous Hamas wants to
wipe Israel off the face of the Earth so
let me be clear we will never let that
happen but that massive show of support
for Israel is at odds with the Biden
State Department a recently leaked
internal memo signed by 100 State
Department employees accuses President
Biden of spreading misinformation about
Israel's conflict with Hamas it also
alleges that the Jewish state is
involved in war crimes it sounds like
something the far-left squad would say
speaking of which those radical
lawmakers were once again calling for a
ceasefire ceas fire means there is no
military solution only a diplomatic and
cultural solution they label us
anti-israel they label us anti-semitic
and they label us
terrorists they lie about us and they
smear
us but we know the truth me calling for
a ceasefire with my colleagues and
centering
Humanity I am uplifting deeply what it
actually means to be Jewish
you know Jesse two starkly different
messages America has been witnessed to
over the last few weeks and that is you
know with the pro-israel it's basically
released the hostages stop the semitism
semitism anti-Semitism and then with the
Hamas group it's basically you know from
The River To The Sea get rid of the Jews
the
anti-Semitism uh and it's a totally
different message how do you think
America is reacting to
this well I believe the American people
are behind the Jewish people because you
take religion out of it it has nothing
to do with that it's right and wrong and
when AOC says there's a diplomatic
solution so what is it has the
congresswoman proposed a diplomatic
solution it's easy to say that anybody
can say that if you got hit with Pearl
Harbor is there a diplomatic solution to
that is there a diplomatic solution to
the Civil War or 911 I don't think there
is and then Omar says iose OS
violence so do I Omar I'm not a Quaker
uh you know if Omar has a son is she
going to teach her son if the sun gets
hit in the face in the schoolyard to not
hit back well that son if he does that
is going to have a very tough life in
the schoolyard there are principles of
just War there's seven principles and
here they are it has to be waged as a
last resort it has to be waged by a
legitimate Authority it has to be a
self-defense against an arm ATT is
always considered a just cause the war
has to be to redress injury a war can
only be just if it is fought with a
reasonable chance of success the
ultimate goal of a just war is to
reestablish peace the violence used in
the war must be proportional to the
injury suffered and then lastly weapons
used in the war must discriminate
between combatants and
non-combatants every single one of those
seven Israel is following every single
one of them so that is a just war and we
had a guest on the other day who said
her parents were in the Holocaust and
she said there is deep concern among the
Jewish people here and all over the
world that if they don't do something
now then there could possibly be another
Holocaust and they talk about how Jewish
friends in Germany were friends up until
one moment and all of a sudden they
weren't friends anymore or they saw a
video of horrible horrible injuries to
Jewish people and they would deny it
they would say that's not happen and
you're seeing the same thing happen
today oh you know there was no they
didn't do anything Hamas is innocent
they didn't do anything I haven't seen
it and and there's deep concern you're
approaching another Holocaust and that's
why another reason why the war is just
you know Greg one of the things that van
Jones spoke about at the rally today he
noted of course that hate crimes against
Jews are up almost 400% in the past
three weeks and he said that many
people's social media algorithms are not
not telling them to the truth now we've
talked about that repeatedly but to hear
it today it it kind of has gotten to the
point where I think people are starting
to recognize that there's a different
Viewpoint based on your algorithms yeah
I I don't know if it matters I mean I
you know do those do those pramas
supporters know that a you know they
just identified the remains of a peace
activist who was burned to death
murdered on October 7th that would be
AOC AOC if she was at the Rave that
would be any of those H any of those Pro
Palestinian peace activists would be
dead if they were there they don't but
they probably don't know that it's
interesting when you look at this March
there were no no one stomping on any
Flags no one screaming at anybody the
difference between the protests is clear
you have adults peacefully focused in
reality what happened versus a tantrum
driven by an ideology you know based on
power you know the Palestinian this prop
Palestinian cause essentially when you
look at it has replaced BLM as a
performative outrage for self-obsessed
screamers because it's all about power
so when you look here you the people
that are Marching for the Jewish State
they have a life the people who are
Marching for their mental state they
actually need a life this is what fills
them up it the the cause is irrelevant
they just like to go out and hear their
own voices and once again I'm going to
say you got to keep it simple one The
War Began in October 7th history is
history Hamas is the guy number two
Israel will and has to respond if they
don't respond that's immoral and it
enables Hamas to continue and repeat the
atrocity and three attacks on Israel are
based on an ideology and not reality
mental state versus Jewish State and the
further away Hamas gets uh Hamas
sympathizers get from October 7th uh
even either through just time or
rhetoric the more likely October 7th
will happen again because that's what
they're hoping for that you forget it
and it goes back to that free punch
Theory they're pissed off because the
Jewish state is supposed to take a free
punch because in the oppressor versus
oppressed filter the oppressed always
gets to hit you the problem is the
so-called oppressed are the oppressors
you know Dana the president uh President
Biden is on his way to meet with XI Jin
ping and he could have delayed that that
visit by a few hours by going to uh th
this March and you know where a lot of
the leaders were should he have gone
well I asked this morning if they he had
been invited and both he and KLA Harris
were invited they declined to go I think
that I would advise go just stop by be a
part of that for a moment raise your
hand in solidarity with uh Johnson and
uh Jeff Schumer and J earn I'm sorry
like the senator from Iowa is Jonie erns
and take that opportunity because in the
next block we're going to talk about
Biden not having the ability to run for
president the way that a president
usually runs and this would have shown
agility flexibility and solidarity on a
day when his administration from both
the state department and the Pentagon
both said that Hamas is hiding
underneath that hospital so it would
have been I think an amazing show of
force I have to tell you I learned about
this march on Sunday I've never wanted
to actually go to a rally I wanted to be
there so I have such fear of missing out
that I wasn't there to be a part of it
heard from friends that it was quite
moving and no one wore masks either
right they didn't have to wear a mask
and people who dare tear down the
posters who boycott Jewish businesses
who go who go into some place like
McDonald's in London and say everybody
needs to leave because these this
business has a business in Israel like
we have to remember that's a distinct
minority they're loud and they're
vicious in some cases but the majority
of people support what would happen
today and I really wish I had been there
with you in spirit I think it was
amazing okay then and Harold you today
Isis released a video calling for
attacks on Jewish people and uh you know
if the squad thinks Israel is committing
genocide what would their response to
this be first it's good to be back
around the table I would hope they would
agree with everything we've said around
the table I think Jesse uh the seven
principles of War um I think are being
followed largely by by our and our our
most important Ally in the Middle East
and I would argue one of our most
important allies around the globe at the
start of this war the Israelis are sort
of this effort response because this was
a self-defense effort on the part of the
Israelis um someone argue that the sixth
and seventh principle about
proportionality and whether or not we're
distinguish between combatants and num
combatants are being followed but I I
don't agree with them I agree with you
but this thing started out the defense
with BB saying the Netanyahu saying one
we must dismantle Hamas two uh we will
recover releasee get the gain release of
hostages to recover our hostages there
now's what I think the administration is
fighting for and in lobbying for uh is a
third piece which is to figure out a way
for uh the Israelis and Palestinians to
coexist after this war after this
self-defense because I don't call it a
war I call it self-defense on the part
of the Israelis whatever the number may
be in terms of how many people have been
killed uh I don't know but I I know one
thing no one likes to see innocent
people killed uh be they Israelis be the
Palestinians or otherwise however in the
real politic of Life uh Wars are messy
self-defense is messy uh October 7th was
tragic so people have every right to
respond but I do think I give the I give
the reason I give the administration a
lot more credit and maybe Dana if we if
you thought about it this way if you
were in the White House you're the only
one that's been in the White House in in
these rooms where this advice has been
given and giving this kind of advice if
the president who it's hard to imagine
people imagine that President Biden is
not supporting Israelis we got two
aircraft carriers there we got $15
billion a there you got sh diplomacy
being done by Blink and for that matter
the president himself went to the region
I think to get I give them credit
because they're thinking about what
happens afterwards and the only way you
have some sort of sustainable two-state
solution and sustainable peace is if
both the Israelis and the Palestinians
can live in some dignity and Safety and
Security where they can live and work
and raise their kids with some
predictability so I give them credit for
that the question is uh can you can you
find moderate Palestinians that want to
do this can you hold Arab support in
that region to do this otherwise it's
just hard for me to imagine my kids are
9 and eight you have young kids our kids
for the next 50 years will be watching
Israel try to manage Gaza and the West
Bank and if that is the solution we're
looking for long term I'm not for that I
think you have to have the Palestinians
and you have to have Arab support in
that region for a long-term sustainable
peace to be achieved hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else